all right I'm gonna be completely honest
okay can I be honest for a sec I'm
always honest on my channel and in being
on is not gonna lie to you that Hercules
movies probably gonna slip right by me
and I'm not gonna talk about it ever
because there's so much [ __ ] to talk
about right now it's just post Comic Con
a lot of stuff that's still happening in
the entertainment world a lot of things
I want to do videos on and not gonna get
to all of it and I gotta allocate what I
can do videos on what's gonna slip by
and that Hercules movie that everyone
who's seen it is indifferent on is
probably gonna slit by cuz I like to
talk about little gems like the one I'm
gonna talk about right now have you guys
seen that Deadpool test footage it's
online right now holy [ __ ] little
background for this thing I guess this
is the test footage that 20th Century
Fox was pitched you know like post x-men
origins Wolverine they were going to
make a Deadpool movie with Ryan Reynolds
still as Deadpool yeah this is it is all
CGI and his Ryan Reynolds doing the
motion capture for Deadpool is his voice
and if you're thinking Oh Ryan Reynolds
is Deadpool you mean Baraka
no not Baraka from Mortal Kombat no this
is completely different this is
different vibe entirely this is
completely Deadpool it starts that
Deadpool's on this overpass it's kind of
singing to himself and he sees the
camera he looks up he's like oh hi there
but you're wondering why the red suit
well that's what the bad guys don't see
me bleed that's the thing about Deadpool
for those of you who don't know he
breaks the fourth wall he knows he's in
a comic book I was always thinking to
myself that would be so awesome to do a
movie like that I mean Deadpool he's all
kicking ass making references
pop-culture references to us he can say
what we're thinking like I don't know if
he slices someone in half we think Oh
Kung Lao for Mortal Kombat he'll be like
hello Kung Lao Mortal Kombat I think it
turn to the screen and be like you were
thinking it I know you were it would be
a really cool interactive character
who's talking to the audience while he's
kicking the ass of the people in the
movie something big blows up he could be
like I cannot believe after x-men
origins 20th Century Fox approved a
budget for this movie it would just be
bafflingly awesome that's really what
this does he lands in this SUV and he's
just kicking the [ __ ] out of all the
guys in there his life there's no easy
way to say this I'm pregnant Trevor BAM
he starts kicking everyone's ass
everyone gets mowed down this
motorcyclist gets off his motorcycle
they start shooting a machine gun at
this SUV that is just tumbling and
Deadpool it shows up it's the best part
he has a drawing of him severing the
head of that guy and he just comes up on
him and then you hear this gang the SUV
tumbles and lands right where the
windows in front of the screen it rolls
down you see this head and is Deadpool
holding the
bird head of the head he just severed
from the dude he's all like crimes the
disease hate the cure well not really
the cure more like a topical ointment
that reduces swelling and itch hi Tom
yes call me angel the money I was like
this is absolutely what I would want a
Deadpool movie to be it's really funny
cuz 20th Century Fox is holding this
footage really close to the chest he's
deleting it off a websites that have it
they're like well we're not making the
movie we don't want you to see that [ __ ]
really weird and this is why I'm doing
this video first and foremost when I met
Nathan Fillion and Clark Gregg when I
didn't interview with him they were both
like oh yeah I've seen your videos you
did one on Firefly and Clark breaks like
oh yeah you did one I agents of shield
that trailer and I met Monty Bennett at
Comic Con he was like oh I saw you
review there oh yeah really lucky you
know just to digiti you know it's very
very fast-paced very high-energy I like
that's my really bad Aussie accent and I
don't care I apologize for none of it
this is what happened and it gets me
thinking like people do see my videos I
do know my work who are in the industry
which tells me one thing Megan Fox
thinks I am a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
fine these are the hits I take for truth
so on the off chance that someone from
20th Century Fox who could get a
Deadpool movie going is watching this
it's like this Deadpool is one of the
top three Marvel heroes Wolverine
spider-man and Deadpool those are the
top three making a Deadpool movie is not
only advantageous because he is a fan
favorite but it would be so different
from any other superhero movie that
exists you make it fans get happy and
you make money you got to speak the
language by the way but all of this is
true is it making sense still no well
then you should not be working that job
just saying you should probably be let
go or talk to someone who can do it
point is this Deadpool teaser footage
I'll put a link below but that link will
probably be dead in about a day and a
half I loved it it is completely
Deadpool it washes away all of that
Baraka from Mortal Kombat nonsense that
was in x-men origins Wolverine a lot of
people are blowing up Twitter and social
networking sites they're like oh this is
awesome footage I really hope the fans
support for this test footage gets a
Deadpool movie going
I always thought Ryan Reynolds would
make a good Deadpool he just has to have
the opportunity to be a good Deadpool
it's possible that they didn't want him
to be Deadpool because then he was Green
Lantern as DC Marvel conflict but since
Green Lantern is just not going to get a
sequel he might as well be dead pool
again so guys have you seen the Deadpool
footage and what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more